julie tu te dépêches oui oui
ah voila voila j'ai trouvé vous êtes là
dépêchez vous casimir est en train de
s'amuser énormément son oncle archibald
lui apporter être électrique
vous allez voir il est en parfaite et
pas de marge il faut que je me dépêche
parce qu'il m'a demandé de lui apporter
le sifflet du chef de garde
vous venez avec moi chaque collectif
l'état merci aux ogm ray bien la voir
casimir a déjà la casquette vendent
accord fort merci voilà vous savez mais
les acteurs will attention les vingt
jours pour l'iodé falanga pur la
traversée par les voies prenez le
passage sous terrain rien n'a pas
casimir bien et bien construisant un
facteur tout où tous les facteurs des
passages à niveau oui oui j'ai alors
écrit faut que je pense au het tellement
préoccupé par mon sifflets m'ont fait me
d'attention aimiez la gare de barrier a
doit être très vigilant mais oui sauf à
face tout moi même le petit frère parti
ou français on dirait que ça ne m'amuse
plus de générer avec mon frein
électrique ce qui chez casimir
franchement ça fait 3 heures que je
regarde tournée ans
ravie d'en prendre un vrai mais comment
vous roulez pas bien si vous voulez
partir mais c'est quasi nous sommes très
heureux dans l'île aux enfants seulement
tu nous fait rêver là à la vapeur des
trains d'autrefois les voyages que
revient enchanter le transsibérien rui
salle pardies bécon-les-bruyères
à la retraite mais fait tout pour les
distraire gsm calciques je ne peux quand
même pas laurent fabriquer un grandeur
nature à il voulait faire un voyage en
train
eh bien je leur ai fabriqué celui-ci
françois ans julie est facteur et de
lait venus vite j'ai une surprise pour
vous qu'est-ce qu'il ya quasiment ses
excès c'est un train voyons là ça c'est
là la locomotive
je les ai fabriqués avec ma machine à
remonter le temps passer le temps d'air
c'est à dire le faux bond à charbon qui
est fait avec la machine à spaghetti
super domicile le wagons de voyageurs
qui est fabriqué avec le banc très bien
dit de casimir c'est bien joli de ça
mais il n'y a pas de raï a baissé
beaucoup plus prudent comme ça on ne
risque pas de dérailler et peugeot grâce
à l'imagination
nous allons pouvoir partir en voyage
mais c'est ça avant la retient julie tu
distribuera les billets à l'aller on
s'en prenait tout son sens françois qui
va s'occuper du charbon bon d'accord
c'est pour moi c'est oui oui mais ses
vêtements un facteur vous avez donné le
signal du départ
d'accord casimir
allez on vous êtes prêts tout le monde y
est attention gros départs sur la route
est tellement petit train part en voyage
attention chercher les nouveaux dangers
papa la fête est très dangereuse elle
ouvrait bien le et je vais essayer de
vous la retirez tous les voyageurs ce
n'est pas de ma faute il y a il ya une
vache sur la voie on va voir
c'est ton travail bonjour mademoiselle
rose aller excusez moi les pourriez vous
allez pas être l'air d'un petit peu plus
loin parce que vous vous bloquez le très
bon attention c'est par rapport à temps
casimir je ne suis pas remonter à tout
d'un coup c'est mon cas s'immiscer c'est
très dangereux
c'est trop risqué
mais non mais non c'est très bien qu'au
public françois renversé lundi
menace-t-il cagim irak immédiatement
chez soi sa chronique
enfin le train s'arrête à l'héroïne
trop d'élèves est votre plus grand soin
ces cas c'est bien enfin ya parfois je
peux pas faire autrement
le train s'est arrêté tout ça il ya plus
de charbon alors mais du charbon si le
peuple accepte ont travaillé que ces
images je suis fatigué moi je suis
essoufflée
c'est fatigant d'être mécanicien
toujours attendre voilà un peu flou on
repart à vue
ro
sega est né
comptez les poteaux télégraphiques qui
défilent devant les yeux éblouis en 16
17 18 19 au les poteaux télégraphiques
ses boutons en bois
que se passe-t-il on voit plus rien
mademoiselle julie nous sommes dans un
tunnel
j'ai horreur de cela et ça empeste la
fumée était le mauvais mais des fois
vous avez le visage tout
[Musique]
osa par le tunnel s'est elle pas merci
merci et bien casimir descendent au
sécher le voyage de terminer à mais pas
pour nous françois non moi il me reste à
conduire le train sur une voie de garage
et toi comme tu es le mécanicien adjoint
tu vas faire le plein de charbon grâce
et les roues nettoyez la locomotive et
les wagons et faire le plein d'eau au
casimir
[Musique]